asked what is a sample of how you
transition between comics as a host
so a very simple transition
is to just keep the show going a lot of
the times a host
will try to piggyback off
one of the comics jokes and they end up
doing some bit
that may or may not work it may or may
not come off as
forced it may or may not ruin the
momentum of that comic set and just
completely reset the room
so a great way to transition in between
comics
especially at like an open mic setting
to where it's like 10 15 20 comics you
just want to keep it you just want to
keep it going
so it's like no give it up for your last
comic here
give it up for dawn everyone and then
they give dawn a round of applause he's
like yeah she was funny all right
all right let's uh let's keep it moving
here your next comment coming up
a local favorite make some noise for
sandy and then they bring up sandy and
you could literally just kind of
move from one to the next just as
seamlessly
as that you don't really have to do
material in between the great part about
being a host
and you guys will hear me say this in
the workshop is that you don't
the pressure's off to be funny as a host
like it really is all about just
setting a fun energy in a fun
environment for a comedy show to happen
so you don't necessarily even have to
kill as a host
which makes it a lot more fun it takes
the pressure off especially
as an early comic to where it's new and
uncomfortable if you
the less pressure you can put on
yourself the better you're going to
perform thanks for watching this clip if
you found these tips helpful and you
want to get involved in our hosting
workshop go into the show description
and request to join our hot breath pro
facebook group so if you're looking to
level up your comedy that is the group
for you